-I'm very glad you're here.
I want to talk about
"The Disaster Artist,"
which I loved, and want
to get to the Golden Globes.
But, one of the things that
happened at the Golden Globes,
and obviously, this happened
in the last couple of days
before we had
you booked on the show
and I'm glad you're still here.
You were wearing a Time's Up
button like a lot of guys
at the show and some women
during your time on stage said
that was hypocritical, they went
to Twitter and said that
it was hypocritical based on
their experiences that
they have had with you.
They made some allegations.
I wonder if you have read
those tweets, and if so,
how you respond to them?
-Yes.
I was sent a couple
of the tweets, so yeah,
I did read them.
I haven't responded.
I think -- Well, the ones
I read were not accurate,
but one of the things that
I've learned is that this is
a conversation that
obviously needs to be had.
There are people, women and
others, who have not been a part
of this conversation,
and I truly believe
and why I was wearing the pin is
that they need to be a part
of this conversation,
and so I support that.
-Ally Sheedy also had a tweet.
She has since took it down.
I heard you mention last night
on Stephen Colbert's show
that you had directed
her in a play.
You've had a good experience
with her.
Have you reached out
to her as someone --
And, are you not curious
as to why she would do that
if you had,
from your perspective,
a good relationship with her?
-Yes, I had a great --
I had a great relationship
with her.
She took the tweet down,
I don't know.
I really don't.
-Not curious enough, though,
to reach out to her as someone
that you've had
a good relationship with before
and to try to understand why
she would have done that?
-[ Sighs ]
I don't know.
I -- [ Sighs ]
It was so shocking.
I don't know.
I just --
I guess I'm just letting it be.
-The last thing I'll say,
or ask about this, I should say,
this moment, you know, I think
this is an exciting time because
it's allowing us all remember,
especially as men,
that there were other people
in different perspectives
for things that we experienced.
Does this Time's Up movement
and this moment we're having
right now, does it make you
look back at all and question
any of your behavior
in the past based on
this new perspective
we're getting on how women
have perceived things
for so long?
-I think what I really learned
and being here and this week
and that show that we were --
You know.
-Mm-hmm.
-I mean, it was so powerful
in there.
-That we heard some
amazing things from
some amazing women.
-Like I said, there are stories
that need to get out.
There are people
that need to be heard.
I have my own side of
this story, but I believe in,
you know, these people that have
been underrepresented getting
their stories out enough
that I will, you know,
hold back things that
I could say just because
I believe in it that much.
And if I have to take a knock
because I'm not going to,
you know, try and, you know,
actively refute things,
then I will, because I believe
in it that much.
-Well, I want to also move on
to the film you made...
-Okay.
-...and thank you for speaking
to me about those things.
I really appreciate it.